this morning we have new evidence from
the investigation of alec baldwin's
accidental shooting incident on the set
of his movie rust law enforcement
officials in new mexico released hours
of video footage including video of
officers questioning him as omar
villafranca reports it was a handgun
that he was holding that went off
killing the movie cinematographer and
wounding the director
are you doing okay no i'm not actually
the videos released monday by the santa
fe county sheriff's office show the
frantic moments as joel souza lies
wounded on the floor of the church set
paramedics attempt to save helena
hudson's life you want to be him
shortly thereafter alec baldwin and the
film's crew members are informed about
hudson's gunshot injuries the exit point
was on her back
left shoulder blade so
she went across it it went it went
through
lifetime
also included is a video showing baldwin
rehearsing with a gun that day
this is what he later told investigators
about the incident i turned the gun the
gun goes off
it's supposed to be a cold gun nothing
no flash charges nothing now
this is a puzzle to me this is making me
very emotional now we see baldwin's
hands being photographed by
investigators as well as photos of guns
and ammunition found on the rust set
we also hear baldwin's reaction after
being shown an image of the projectile
that injured the director
as i suspected somebody put a live
ground in the gun
more than six months later it's still
unclear what led to the fatal shooting
officials say the investigation remains
open as they analyze baldwin's cell
phone
and wait for ballistic evidence from the
fbi
no criminal charges have been filed but
the production company has been fined
nearly 137 thousand dollars for safety
violations multiple civil cases have
been filed against baldwin and the
production company including a wrongful
death suit by hutchins family what
remains unclear is how the videos will
impact those cases in civil court for
cbs mornings i'm omar villafranca
it's really tough looking at that video
knowing what had just happened and what
everyone was reacting to and every time
i see it i think about helena hutchins
family i know who's now looking at that
too yeah
yeah what's striking to me in the video
is just how numb everyone is yeah as
it's all unfolding i'm still in shock
yeah yeah a lot of questions though i
feel in shock watching it's so sad